what did i say when i was like babe i'm
going to take my birth control what did
you say i gave you a reason why i've
seen women who were on birth control and
when they wanted to conceive it was very
how do you know that they just told you
that oh my goodness
well i just said pull out yeah
i pulled out when we started and then
you told me you have this application on
your phone
like i'm not ovulating right now you
can't me
i don't know how i'm gonna be able to
face your family if you're pregnant
i'm living in your father's house and
you know it's just too much
well you can't work the pressure's all
on me to work and save all the money
it's just too much right now can we talk
about it yes let's wait until we get
yeah it's too much for you but it's even
more for me like you don't even
understand
i love babies like i want to have a lot
of kids it's just not the right time
i mean we're not even married yet we're
still living in my parents basement
let's go
and on top of that
my dad only has one rule for us and
that's not to get pregnant
one thing's for for sure you better not
get pregnant okay
it's fine we're not gonna have any more
kids
in this house
[Music]
here they are you follow me yeah
should have got condoms
[Music]
i'm gonna be like now because
i really don't want to like bring these
home and like risk someone finding them
oh
okay
it's hard enough trying to figure out
our relationship together um do you guys
have a bathroom
back there thank you
but
the hardest thing for me right now i
just put a whole lot of money on the
ring
and
i don't have the finance to be able to
take care of my family
so
emily is pregnant right now
i don't know how we're going to be able
to handle these
[Music]
moment of truth
[Music]